each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon everyone pleasure for me
to introduce pescado fois
but skull is a professor at the Ecole
Polytechnique fédérale de Lausanne in
Switzerland and we go back a long way
we are Pascal was working at SR I
international in Menlo Park when I
briefly worked there in 1989 and he's
one of the pioneers in multi-view stereo
he's done some of the most interesting
work in person tracking recently over
the last decade tremendous amount of
work on fast and efficient feature
descriptors which is what he's going to
talk about today another interesting
topic is that his work on deformable
surface modeling led to his being hired
as a consultant by the Swiss national
Racing team for sailboat racing so he
has written software to spy on other
people's sailboats and figure out why
their sails are working so well so it's
a great pleasure to introduce Pascal
thank you hi so today I'd like to to
talk about our work on the binary
descriptors and to to give you a context
and maybe to tell you how we got
interested into this by this let me tell
you something you probably already know
which is one of the things we are all
interested in doing is being able to run
around the city look at take pictures of
landmarks with our cell phones and being
able to click to point at a particular
statue in this case this one and have
some information pop up about the statue
which means of course that we need two
things we need a a model of in this case
the Cathedral it has to be annotated and
it has to be precisely registered with
the image we just took to be able to so
that the phone will know that when you
point it at to pick your pixel you were
talking about this pick your statue
so there are two main components in this
one is the 3d models and preferably they
have to be large scale because in the
end we want to do a whole city a whole
country the whole world eventually it's
going to become very very big and once
you have that you want to be able to
take the image you just took and match
it against the spot potentially
extremely large models so first let me
say a few words about the malls
themselves and how we build them and in
a sense this is a follow up of things
that have be done here
it's Photosynth taken maybe to the next
level and the problem is when you try to
do this is say you are here are a few
pictures of lausanne where we are and
the number of grad students went around
with digital cameras and took pictures
of the city and typically what happens
when you do that is you get pictures of
landmarks like the cathedral taken from
very different angles they don't look
the same at all and it's not trivial to
match them and to produce models three
points like those and I know that there
is this very famous paper about
realistic Rome in a day but it didn't
really reconstruct Rome it reconstructed
three very important landmarks in Rome
which is slightly different and that's
actually fairly typical about a state of
the art approaches they tend to
reconstruct disconnected clusters
because mostly you have lots and lots of
pictures usually for specific locations
but in between those locations you have
very few pictures it's very sparse and
most Butler's tend to disconnect them
then of course there is a problem that
if you are going to do bond adjustment
on very very large scale it tends to
explode unless you you're careful about
it and finally a lot of the
the three deep the three recursive
techniques also tend to choke if you
give them too many images over too wide
a range so these are things we've been
trying to work on and one of the things
we've paid much attention to is being
able to register images like this which
are taken from very very different
viewpoints and to do this what we've
done is taken advantage of the fact that
most images you can find have some form
of geotag GPS data and also that most
city I mean it's not terra incognita you
typically for for most cities in the
world you have a cadastral map a map of
the buildings it may or may not be
accurate but it gives you a pretty good
idea of what's there and so the system
we've developed essentially take takes
all the images that you have for
Lausanne for example we have about
twenty thousand and we'll like most of
the other state-of-the-art systems
essentially group them into clusters but
then when we do the bomber adjustment we
use the GPS data and the cadastral
information to make sure that the
clusters align with each other and with
a commercial map so that we can in this
large-scale consistent model of the
whole city and of course it has to take
into account the fact that sometimes
they're not there and sometimes they are
ping wrong but that's when you do vision
that's normal
dealing with outliers is normal and so
we can build reconstruction to this one
where what's interesting about this is
we've used images very different kinds
of images from different sources some
from drones shown from these
ground-level images taken with one
peeler camera and so I'm actually images
where actually we zoomed in the the
Cathedral to produce
the high-res stuff
and actually that here we need some help
from the graphics folks you can you
probably saw it when we switch
resolution there was a jump and really
there shouldn't be a chump but that's us
poor computer vision folks don't we
don't know how to do this anyway so the
point of this is we're building smalls
this one is not particularly but you can
build much bigger one with thousands and
thousands of images and you can
visualize it but now if we if you
actually want to use it what's going to
be needed is a way to take a new image
and register it against this model so
this Mars wedding it has 3d points and
for all these 3d points it's going to
have to do it's going to contain
descriptors so typically they could be
sift descriptors which is more Leicester
state that the art still and that's fine
if you have unlimited amounts of memory
but typically if you're on a cell phone
you don't have a limited amounts of
memory if and if the model is really
really big with millions and millions of
descriptors you end up with a problem
you need to be able to have smaller
descriptors so that you use less memory
and also so that you can do the matching
faster and that's actually where the
binary descriptors come in what I'm
going to argue is that if you replace
the floating-point descriptors by binary
descriptors you gain in memory size you
gain in speed and you don't really lose
in accuracy so they are a good thing
so that's that's the program is to try
to show that binary descriptors are much
more compact they can be they'll lead to
faster matching because essentially the
Hamming distance is faster to compute
that then the lydian distance and you if
you compute those magnitude correctly
you don't really lose with respect to
the more traditional ones ones like
shift officer so this is actually
something we've been looking at for a
long time and this is a now fairly old
video where what we used with something
called Ferns where we had actually
trained a classifier to recognize
interest points on the little car and
every time the car comes into view so
now it's hidden it doesn't find it but
when it comes into view it does the
mashing very very fast and if we detect
the car so this particular in this for
your video there is there is no temporal
consistency imposed it's read detection
at every frame independently and the
principle behind this was to was a
classification based approach to
matching where if you take a key point
here the corner of the M for example you
know that if the surface is locally
planar all possible appearances of that
M or that corner are going to be this
patch up to some homography
so what we did was to produce a training
database of all the possible views of
that key point I mean not all possible
user errors a representative sample and
then we trained a decision tree based
classifier to recognize those key points
so that you you would drop a patch at
the top of a tree and then you would ask
questions like is this pixel brighter
than this one
if yes you go left if no you go right
and we had trained a classifier to do
this and the point of this of course it
is that doing this classification is
extremely fast it only is a binary
descriptor because it's all based on
this sample simple yes/no questions and
so we could actually train it either by
if the object was truly planar like the
cover of the book just and synthesizing
tomography zuv the key points
or if the object was non planar like
like little car by essentially using OOP
well yeah this is a video by essentially
showing to the system a video of the
object the video in which the motion was
really nice and slow so that tracking
was easy and generating a Jin and so we
could generate our training database in
this way so that worked nicely and some
of our colleagues and grads know a while
ago implemented that in a cell phone and
we got real-time performance on that
phone but the problem with this is that
it requires a lot of training so the
runtime performance was good but
training took took a long time so there
was no real way with that particular
algorithm to just show an image and and
then very very quickly say learn it and
use it and then having trained the trees
try to find it again which is why more
recently we move to actually something
that's simpler than this which is
actually the first true binary
descriptors we've been playing with
which is something we call brief and
brief is really really simple which is
what you do to describe a patch you take
the patch you smooth it and then only
smooth patch you ask a bunch of
questions of the you take pairs of
points and for each pair you ask is this
one brighter than this one
if the answer is yes it's one if the
answer is no zero and typically you
could do do you can choose about 256 of
these pairs which means you boil down
your patch to 26 bits vector so this is
really simple and the surprising thing
is it works very well in terms it's a
pretty powerful descriptor with well
I'll show you but you can use 128 256 or
512 of these tests and it's basically
enough and another surprising thing is
how do you choose the tests so we tried
many many different strategies in the
end we were not able to truly improve
upon doing it just randomly just pick a
bunch of random tests we get a smidgen
better by biasing a little bit of
probability so that it would be more in
the center but very slightly and not
terribly significantly
one pixel long segments don't believe as
much descriptive power and very long
ones maybe punches large weight we could
but in fact we know we didn't we again
we could try but I suspect it might be
yield a very small improvement but
nothing terribly significant but it's
actually what this is computing out
derivatives you can think of these as
gradients and the long ones are
gradients over long that's which is why
we need a smoothing by the way otherwise
they wouldn't be meaningful gradients
and so we first tested that on some of
the standard benchmark data sets with
some mostly planar structures and
substrate that not planar for which we
have lidar data and so if you compare it
to surf it does better yeah I won't go
into the detail level the curves but
typically we get recognition rates that
tend to be better so the test we are
playing is we take 512 points in one
image 512 in the other and we measure
how many of the correspondences
established using these descriptors are
the right ones so the percentage is is
somewhat higher with one something that
you should notice what we are comparing
against mostly is is something called
you surf so surf is designed to be
orientation invariant our brief is not
brief is definitely not orientation
invariant so what we compared against
something called you surf which is surf
without the orientation invariance which
actually does Barron surf when
orientation invariance is not needed the
second important detail you pay a price
for orientation and independence
so in applications where you don't need
it don't use it typically if you have a
cellphone that you know the orientation
because you have an inclinometer you
should use a non orientation invariant
descriptor
so we tend to do better on these
benchmarks and of course surf
essentially is a fast version of sift
with some loss of performance so on some
of the benchmarks actually should we
still do bear and surfed but not on
others on others actually we sift sift
is still more powerful than brief so
it's a very and wavy thing but roughly
based on this test the recognition
accuracy of brief is somewhere between
that of sift and serve the other thing
that especially for the for all the
students see here is be careful of mesh
marks you can I mean depending how you
present these graphs I could have argued
about anything because by choosing the
right graph to show you but that's
actually not the point of brief the
point of brief is not to be more
accurate and safe this to be much faster
and that it is so here are some
computational issues combinational times
so on that was done I think it was a Mac
like this one and here is the kind of
time it takes so if you use surf it
takes for a certain amount of time and
if you use brief it's of course a much
much shorter so of course there is a
version of surf on the GPU which is much
better than the version of that surf
without the GPU but the point here is we
can do better than surf on the GPU
without a GP this is still a cpu and one
other thing that speeds it up a lot is
that the the new CPUs have you can
compute essentially the Hamming distance
which what you use extremely fast it's
one instruction so that's one of the
reasons why you want to use
binary descriptors so one more word
maybe about skin and rotation invariant
so definitely brief is neither scale nor
rotation invariant but it's very fast so
if you do need scale and rotation
invariance what you can do is you have
for each key point you you learn rotated
versions of it so of course you pay a
price but it's an acceptable price and
so this is the kind of thing it'll do is
this a very very simple demo where you
just show a thing to the computer you
say here is my area of interest and then
immediately because there is no learning
you can start tracking it and you as I
talk as I told you don't believe
benchmarks try the code and actually
I've heard that some some of you already
have so now that we did what I just
described and we that was the paper we
we published at ECC V and then we send
it for a journal publication and then
the reviewers told us well that's all
very nice but why don't you try this on
on a more challenging and more a newer
benchmark data set like the Liberty data
set which actually has this interesting
property so these are small images of
the Statue of Liberty and it's really 3d
and it's actually more it's true it's
more complicated than the ones I've
shown before especially it has much more
images much more key points so we did
and here are the results we get when we
are using more and more key points so
the previous examples we're done with
512 key points in each image so we were
kind of it's kind of taking a graph
through this these slides we are set
here we have surf here and
we have brief here in the middle and
what happens is actually as you increase
the number of images essentially you
there is a fairly big difference between
sift and between sift and brief and
actually there is also something that we
didn't like too much but that's life
that there's a crossover so we still can
beat surf but we have to use more bits
which after all is not too completely
unreasonable but the problem is now that
we are going if you are going towards
more key points and I didn't plot what
happens here the descriptive power of
brief is not sufficient because in the
end the problem I'm trying to address is
not matching a few hundred key points is
going into a database where I'm going to
have millions and millions and millions
of them
so in that case we are going to do
something to search into these large
databases we're going to need something
more powerful and the way we we try to
get that is by going back to our
Lausanne model so back to what I
discussed earlier we have built a cabin
mall of Lausanne with 4,500 images so a
million or so 3d points and 10 million
feature points because each one of not
each one but a lot of the 3d points are
visible in many images so actually this
is a pretty good database and it has an
important feature that I don't think
many people exploit but it's an
important one which is if you if you are
reasoning in terms of 3d point that you
know that this point and that point and
that point are the same 3d points it
means that your descriptors in terms of
the descriptors this that and that
should match even though they may have
very different appearances because in
terms of the sift descriptor they could
be very different because
they are seen from very different
perspectives so another way to look at
this as you can look at the the Venice
that data set you can register it in the
same way and what you get is I mean it's
hard to see on the slide but you can see
that you have the same key points on San
Marco that's seen in many many many
images so what we did is we took I think
the the Venice data set is not sure
isn't it you doesn't come from here I
think it's a sign man
yeah
so they don't open there is venison
Marco is one of the classic scenes
that's been reconstructed by motor
tourism I'm not sure yet but I think it
started here okay and it may have grown
since Uranus has some a lot of different
sources with everybody each day's that
it's gonna be biased I think it's what
you're getting at it's like assignments
are kind of bias by the citizen detector
but I mean let me let's go back it's
good point but let's go back to that
because the laws on data set is going to
play a key role in this and we can
discuss after that if it's biased or not
so anyway so we have this large data set
with many images of Venice and one thing
we did is you take I think the 24 24
feature points that are found in more in
the longest track we could find the 24
longest track we could find so each
track contains a feature points seen in
many images for each of them we can
compute the the sift vector and we can
plot a confusion matrix so each block
here correspond to this the the the sift
descriptors for the same 3d points seen
in many images so ideally this image you
should have zeros on the blocks diagonal
blocks and large values everywhere else
that would be the ideal description
would do this so SIF doesn't quite do
that it definitely reasonable of course
it works but it doesn't quite do that
and so what I would like to talk about
now is this descriptor that we call LD a
hash which is going to be a binary
descriptor such that the confusion
matrix in Hamming space is better
behaved than this one so this one you
can see that you have the blue on on the
on the diagonal and everywhere else
it's kind of reddish I mean it's a large
distance everywhere which is not quite
true here you have a lot you here you
are some blue even off-diagonal which
you shouldn't have ideally you think we
could okay so we could try that we could
try that but I'm going to show you when
we do the real test that I think not but
good okay so what we are trying to
achieve to ideally to get this thing to
be the way we want it what we are trying
to achieve is to start from our
descriptors our floating-point
descriptors which in this case they're
going to be sift descriptors and binary
is that binarize them in such a way so
the binary sing is to the capital B so
that the distance is between those that
correspond to the same point so the same
2d points are minimized and here I'm
sorry there's it should be a minus sign
those between the distance between those
in that are belong to different points
should be are maximized or so the old
energy is minimized if you put the minus
here and in this case being is going to
be very there are very many ways to
penalize something but the simplest one
is you just do a projection and your
threshold so there you can't get much
simpler than that and the reason for
doing it this way or one of the reasons
for doing this way is finding the P to
the projection matrix that minimizes
this criterion can be done in close form
it's basically you compute the
appropriate matrices
you look for the you do an SVD you look
for the smallest eigen values and you
got it
and similarly computing your threshold
can be done as a second step and it can
be it can be done dimension by dimension
by doing a simple 1d line search so
which means that computing this can be
done in closed form essentially which is
in contrast to many of the other
techniques that are around where you
typically have a greedy search or you
need a search dimension by dimension
with no explicit guarantee of finding a
global minimum in this case we do and
they are of course a couple of
parameters in this actually there are
two parameters there is one is this
alpha parameter so how do you weigh the
positive examples against the negative
ones and then what is going to be the
national ID of your binary descriptor so
the size the number of lines in your P
matrix and here are some curves so the
test I'm going to present are all done
this way what we are going to do is we
are going to take a point a descriptor
and we are going to see to plot the the
false positive rate as a function of the
threshold and distance we put against
the true positive rate and so here the
curves so this is alpha so infinity
means you're not using the negative
examples you're only using the positive
examples and for one thing it's not
incredibly if you look at the the 120
for 128 bits that's the size of the
descriptor it's not incredibly sensitive
to the value of alpha you choose so in
practice we choose something around 10
and and the dimensions are and the
dimensionally of course you do better
when you have 128 that when you use 64
64 is not quite enough but 128 does a
pretty good job and now we can do some
comparisons we do this test using sift
or using our LD hash descriptor and
fairly consistently in this very low
false positive rate area we do better
so they're actually interesting I mean
that's at least in that range LD a hash
seems to do better in circuit even
though it's a binary vector it has fewer
bits but what it does have is because we
have this learning the supervised
learning technique it's learns it
apparently has learned something that
seems to carry over
remember we forced it and lastly I think
that's key we forced it to to produce
similar binary vectors for all
descriptors corresponding to the same 3d
points even though their appearance
might have been quite different because
because of changes in perspective yes
ya know there is still because in
infinity it just means it just mean that
this term goes away
it's just infinity means alpha controls
the weight of the of the positive one
again the negative ones so infinite just
means in practice when we in a code when
we say infinity it means just ignore it
make it one and forget about this one
Roseanna sorry boy the descriptors from
a no so that's something that's that
gets back to to the point you made
earlier
he's a training was done in on the loss
and data set we don't retrain no they're
not the training is done in Lhasa
on Lausanne so we essentially in the end
what we've learned is one matrix P and
one set of vectors and when dr. T from
Lausanne and then we use these two baton
rise in on these other on Dresden Venice
and all the others so it seems that's
actually a little surprising Lausanne
seems to capture at least I don't
exactly know how broad it is but broad
enough at least to work on all these
other data sets so where we have curves
that are significantly above what you
can do with sift
again in the very low false positive
range and that's for this particular
kitchen that's where we want to work in
because if you have millions and
millions of data sets of points in your
database if you have if you don't have a
very low false positive rate you are
going to be overwhelmed by the number of
points you find and your computation
will become very slow
okay so I'm going to very good point
this is exact nearest neighbors this is
just nearest neighbor we don't worry
about time it's very slow but the enn is
a big issue I'm going to talk about it
but for the purpose so join that graph
it's just nearest neighbors so how many
points are within for a very low
threshold the only only the points that
correspond to the same only descriptor
the crust for the 3d point will be found
it's the threshold on the distance with
all the points of one what are the
inputs in the it's it's a patch is how
many among those you find is how many
patches that are not the right one so
the difference between point zero zero
one and point zero one is whether
one-tenth of a percent or 1 percent of
yours
it's okay let's confess I don't have the
formula in my head can we can I answer
that dr. dark okay okay so Prague EPFL I
mean it's all kind of the same so this I
think that's sort of interesting it
seemed it looks like by training on this
one dataset this one Lausanne dataset
we've essentially learned something
about the redundancies of sect in
general and it carries over to all these
other datasets now back to the message
is I've just said essentially Lda hash
- bear insert at least on its particular
task with that but your way of computing
the false body raised that we should go
into afterwards but if you remember
another graph I showed before I showed
you a graph where sift was doing better
this is LD a hash where LD was shift was
doing better than LD hash so actually
what's happening and that actually it's
interesting because this is one pammi
paper this is a different penny paper
and I put together this talk and I
looked at this graph say huh what's
happening and what's happening I think
and actually that's something we might
be discussing is it's not the same task
so better it's you when you say
something is better than something else
you have to say better for what and in
fact what's happening is this is looking
for a point in in a very large database
and having very few false positives this
is about matching all points in this
real small set and what I believe and I
have to check and I haven't checked this
what's happening here correspond to what
happens at this end of the curve so the
order what I'm showing you is for the
very low false positive rates if you
looked at the order at the very high
positive rates false positive rate the
or
would not be the same so again
beware of benchmarks and what I would
advise if you're interested this try it
because so the the Lausanne data set is
on the web the code for idea hash is on
the web - and how the code in this case
is nothing it's a nature
it's a header it's a matrix and a bunch
of thresholds okay so in summary what
I've shown you is that you can take sift
you can binarize it and at least for
some for a class of tasks you actually
don't lose any accuracy you even gain
some which we tried is the the
performance is lower actually what you
could do it you couldn't do an
intermediate thing where you have a
random projection matrix but you choose
your thresholds carefully I think you
would still we haven't explicitly done
that but he would you okay in some sense
there's this P matrix and this T vector
the T vector is almost mostly more
important than the P matrix okay so okay
so now we have all these binary vectors
we can compute them using the technique
I just described but maybe you have a
better technique in all case this is
going to get back to what you mentioned
that
now that you have binary vectors where
you can do the test using linear nearest
neighbor search which is fine the slope
again if we're you and in the ID that
you have millions and millions of points
it's not going to be practical so you
have to go too near nearest Nate
approximate nearest neighbor search and
the problem is something that surprised
us is I am not aware of many algorithms
that you
designed for this there are lots and
lots of algorithms for a and then for
floating-point descriptors but the
problem is if you try them on binary
vector you can always treat to be the
binary vector as a fully point vector if
you want but you lose a lot on
performance they don't work very well
except one which is the higher goal K
means if you use real valued centroids
so you take your binary vectors and you
think averages of them but then if you
take averages of them they become
clothing point vectors and you lose the
advantage because now you have to
compute a collision distances again so
that was a somewhat surprising finding
and if you think about it it's also
makes it sort of makes sense because
Hamming spaces are different from clean
spaces they are difference in the sense
that the boundary between two points the
set of points that are equidistant from
two points is thick so if you hear what
I'm plotting is in Hamming space the
boundaries between the points that are
closer to this one or closer to this one
to V it's thick there are lots of them
whereas in a million space it's of
measure zero in fact you can compute
these things and you can show that there
are very simple formulas that says that
the the number of points that are
equidistant from two arbitrary points in
your space is very significant it's
definitely not of measure zero and that
actually confuses most standard
algorithm for a NN which essentially
assume that the boundary is is of
measure zero and I think that is the
explanation for why those ten algorithm
most of these standard algorithm
degrades so actually that's something we
just began working on is okay so how can
you do algorithms for a and then that
who's performant and does not degrade
and still work all
on the manga vectors to so as to remain
fast so one thing we did which work
pretty well or something we call a park
tree for a petition around a random
Center which is essentially the same
thing as a hard coal came in trees
except for the fact that instead of
taking your Center when you subdivide
the tree to be the average you take one
point at random and you do that several
times so against a very very simple
algorithm and you rely you rely on
randomness because you have several of
these trees to get the right answer or
something that's even simpler which is a
form of LSH on the binary vectors and
this goes as follows you
you have your binary vectors you select
a random number of bits you produce a
hash key with those and you put your
your your vectors in the right bins you
got several times again you rely on
random randomness and that actually
works well and what we get with these
algorithms is on relatively large here
we had we tried that on databases with
500k 900 K and 1.5 million descriptors
and there we get something that actually
runs much much faster for the same
accuracy as a state of the art methods
because everything remains binary we
never compute a you clean distance and
we can exploit these the fact that the
mine CPUs can confuse Hamming distance
very fast and actually they are really
case is what helps so for example here
is a practical example of something we
use this for which is the case of our
translation I mean this is kamli
standard use you overfly an area you
take lots of images that's a very big
images and you want to register them to
produce auto photos and 3d models
and in this case this small example was
a sorry what we had we had 25 relatively
big images of town in South of France so
bad 400k feature points per image and to
do this registration you need to do
nearest neighbor search and so with this
this faster enn approaches that gives
you a 20 folder speed of speed-up over
using the binary the floating-point
vectors and actually this sort of
matters because so we're trying to
follow the great American tradition of
the startup and so we actually one of
the game we are playing is trying to
develop a product that essentially can
be used in conjunction with these small
drones like this one where you just
launch it by hand it will land by itself
it in this case it collects images of
the of the EPFL campus and eventually
what it will come back with is another
photo and or a 3d model of the whole
thing and of course none of this is
incredibly new I mean is that at least
have been known for a long time but if
you are trying to turn into product has
to be robust it has to be totally
automatic nobody wants to touch anything
and it has to be robust though in those
cases the actually the fact that 20
times speed-up is not a vegetable
because the guy who wants a photo
doesn't want to wait and so that's
hopefully oh that's okay so this is I
mean let me stop this okay so let me go
to the end okay so this is this is
another so this is called the official
name is the Rolex Learning Center also
known informally as a learning cheese
because of no other Swiss holes in the
on the top of it which is a very
interesting building actually because
it's it's a there is nothing there is
nothing plainer and there it's just
rolling forums and so the architects had
fun and it's good for us because it in
terms of architectural reconstruction
it's more fun to reconstruct them and
then a bunch of boxes okay so to
conclude I have presented two kinds of
binary descriptors one brief is really
as simple as it gets
it's just based on doing these binary
tests it's extremely fast to compute so
and it's quite effective for matching
images against each other as long as you
not too many for relatively small
databases it works very well and it's
well adapted for cases where you were
very limited CPU another which is more
sophisticated it's more completely
intensive because you have first to
compute shift and then binarize it but
then is adapted to finding points to
being searches in extremely large
databases and the interesting part is at
least for this bigger task you really do
not lose any accuracy or something
except you even gain some because you've
trained a thing appropriately and now
what's needed to really use these in a
real application are techniques to do a
and n search on truly truly large
databases quickly and then one of the
things we are looking into is exploring
the fact that we are not doing any an
arbitrary n n search we are doing an N
and search for architectural style
things where I mean location matters so
once you've found the descriptor once
you've done one match you can expect
that the next one is going to be a point
in the vicinity in a geography in a
geography called vicinity and you should
actually build that into your
and that's one of the things we are
going to keep looking at in the future
that's it thank you while these two
alternative things that you presented
one which binarized is perfect
excellent densities it's spider Isaac
directly on working directly on the
patch coming up with a binary vector
other one is really computing sift for
us there's no other way to you have to
compute sift or some kind of complicated
mu8 descriptor and then you binarize so
what why doesn't the first white boil
way don't you think the first technique
does you can really not scale for large
images or is it something is there a
better way to do it that can be a mean
that will be going I mean so you
suggested the way I mean sift has been
carefully thought thought out to be no
capture all these small K large scale
effects and we are capitalizing on that
so baby as were suggested if you had a
brief style thing with the test
organized in the right way maybe you you
should be able to capture some of the
same things because what happens we sift
is the three it seems to be redundant in
many ways since you can decimate it and
still not lose its distributive power so
I think the short it is intriguing and I
think there is more to be there's
something to be looked at in this to
visualize the way similarly at the
weight this we have a waiting right on
switch which features are important
the LPA hatch and no we haven't we show
the baby interesting visual identity
whiskey
even the trees before the first actually
trained the tests maximize on-screen
incredible training whether that's the
point of grief is to completely get rid
of the training
so essentially what he's saying in some
senses you don't even need the training
is not that that was including the ferns
is not all that necessary you can do
without but that would be true with the
ferns would mean the complete randomness
of the test is the same in the ferns and
the and in brief so we've not again that
goes back to what we just discussed you
would think that there should be an
optimum way to select the test but we
haven't found it the department years
nearest part you sure that you can make
it much faster to achieve the same
precision but
can it also just the the chart of
precision that you showed for the for
the case in some weight sector five how
much better than that can you get to but
you could you can never I mean in this
it's your thing you cannot beat the
linear it depends how much time we
willing to spend right that's why it's
it's a time as as a time for query the
new surface
in the bottom the the bottom acts so the
others are you know is various
parameters and HTM as Michael k-means
and soui do you know what portion in the
case of these binary vectors what
fortune of say using the KQ treatise
slow is it the see you can understand
such stores it down right so but as
opposed to the degrees well the KD trees
do not have the thick bounty they are
slow because you you could in this case
they're so because since you compute the
means you don't have take boundaries
anymore it becomes Euclidean again so
the thick boundary problem goes away but
the price you pay is now you have to do
these floating-point computations
okay so Katie yeah the Katie tree the
one I described was a higher call
k-means sorry so he the one that works
best is the uncle for this bigger
problem is a hard call k-means and the
the examples to show that here were
matching aerial photos to each other
have you done it with ground level
photos yes so for the a n n have we done
this yes we have because some of these
models are based on the laws on models
but the laws are no I showed you was the
video where it was we use some the
ground level images so yes but you have
a system now where somebody could just
walk up take a picture somewhere in
those on and it'll tell you where you're
standing we don't have we don't have one
we could in a sense that something we'd
put on the web now right yeah deploy
such a system would it successfully
match the image or
they're just too many images that we've
come up for retrieval the office that's
a large number of images probably even
worth the number of drone images right I
think we haven't really tested it you
know getting a dafaq showed us these
photos and what was under instructions I
thought you were heading towards a
system which we take an arbitrary you
thought over tell you where we are we
are heading in that direction between
so it was for brief so I said that about
brief to compensate for the orientation
invariance so we didn't brief we will
use it on these indoor applications so
we didn't try it's more you know these
are my reality things on your cell phone
kind of things we've been playing with
so it's really not that that's what I
was trying to explain it's not it's
adapted for that but it's not truly
adapted for the large-scale stuff
so initially we you sift like everyone
else and now that we've trained Elliot
Hirsch we use earlier
any other questions thank you